what up space fam golson here from anime
uproar back at it again to discuss the
latest
epic chapter of one piece and wow this
was a glorious
chapter so make sure to stay tuned for
this one if you do enjoy
seeing these one piece chapter reviews
every week and you want to keep them
coming the best thing you could do is
hit that like button like really smash
it and share this video with your nakama
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select
all or you will miss future one piece
videos and while you wait for the next
chapter to drop
feel free to check out our growing one
piece playlist where i got videos about
the yonko
warlord supernova and more and i just
uploaded the longest video ever to be
uploaded on
our anime uproar channel about every
yonko's backstory so i'll link that in
the description as well
along with the full one piece playlist
now without further ado
let's jump into it spoilers and all so
this chapter starts where we left off
with kiku badly injured kiku just got
shankst
aka just lost an arm that's the damage
we saw
and i thought we might get even more
from dragon kaido's win slashes
but let's keep going to find out sulong
inuarashi lets his men know to get off
the roof
as we saw last chapter it's an extremely
dangerous place to be even for the most
skilled the red scabbards help kiku
kinemon uses his flaming sword to close
kiku's fresh
wound props to kiku who is so damn
inspiring in this chapter
no tears we just see a smile which is
crazy
imagine losing your arm and someone
putting a flaming sword to the wound
and after all that you respond by just
smiling that is some epic stuff right
there
and not only that kinemon asks can you
stand kikunojo
and kiku responds of course these kinds
of moments are what i love the most
about shonen we see such amazing
examples of characters acting
so epic that we can use as role models
and draw inspiration from them i
personally got frustrated yesterday
and get this it was because my amazon
fire stick was taking too long to load
and then i read something like this and
wow it really puts things in perspective
real quick
mad respect for kiku and kaido two a
yonko approves
they are enemies but kaido praises
kiku's unwavering resolve
saying that's how it should be again we
keep getting that sense of respect
and honor from kaido that is completely
absent in villains like orochi he
compares himself to roger and whitebeard
who like him
likes the samurai and how they live
their lives
and even face injury and death in such a
stoic manner and with honor
kaido has obviously failed to live up to
this warrior code that the samurai
follow when he used a distraction to
beat odin
and when he went back on his word by
shooting him but he respects people that
actually follow this code and as a
result we can deduce
that he resents himself whether
consciously or unconsciously
for falling short of it in the past and
this resentment manifests itself i would
argue in depression binge drinking and
attempts at his own life
that's my take at least but i'm sure
we'll find out even more
as we finish up this arc then we get a
pretty cool acknowledgement from kaido
that the samurai put up a good fight and
we get a glimpse into his philosophy as
he transforms
back to his humanoid and more powerful
form he says
it is not with the advancement of time
but rather in death that humans truly
attain perfection
and this is interesting stuff
philosophers of the past have gone as
far as to say the whole purpose of
practicing philosophy
is to learn how to die well and many
have believed that our most
important test is how we face our own
death and that a man or woman can't
truly be judged before
that and getting an antagonist like
kaido sharing similar sentiments about
the importance of death
is pretty hype for me as a philosophy
stan
kaido seriously says let's end this and
now
that he's in his more powerful form it
seems like he's showing respect to the
samurai and getting serious
kinemon responds that being killed by
kaido would bring them no honor
but i must say how they face their death
could very well bring them honor
whether it comes from kaido or someone
else then we jump to luffy
jinbei and sanji still running to
kinemon this running reminds me a bit of
when goku and dragon ball z says for
multiple episodes that he's coming to
the main fight and he's almost there
they've definitely been working their
way there for a while but still the
scabbards have been keeping the fight
interesting
and the running scenes have been comedic
not gonna lie for example people mention
oh no
it's straw hat and jimbei they're
incredibly strong so we gotta watch out
for them
but sanji gets mad kicking them for not
mentioning blacklight sanji
of course he would get jealous about
something like this luffy says he's
rushing to kick idol's butt
again it sounds hilarious after their
last encounter
but i can't wait to see why luffy is so
confident this time despite what
happened last time and we get some great
moments very reminiscent of one punch
man
where we get antagonists introducing
themselves in epic fashion
giraffe hamlet amazing name by the way
says that our guys
are mediocre and that day the bad guys
will be exceeding expectations while
chicken 4 tricks
says quiet down the strong or silent in
action
you'd think that the silent one if not
the cocky one would put up a bit of a
fight despite the fact that he has a
chicken butt for a head
these guys are headliners after all but
sanji and jinbei take them out
effortlessly it is very nice seeing it
done
and of course their underlings are
crying out to their leaders who have
just been wrecked by people just passing
by
you gotta appreciate such hilarious
moments
i mean come on the dude's head was right
where the chicken's butt would be
hilarious then we got queen's ice plague
spreading as mentioned last chapter
to our guys and to beast guys as well
you even have
underlings asking why queen is dragging
them into it
but queen clearly doesn't care much
about his subordinates
especially pleasures who failed to gain
animal traits after eating a smile fruit
and due to side effects now always laugh
slash smile
no matter how bad the situation seems
queen in a cold cold-hearted manner
pun intended mentions that the pleasures
should make themselves useful for once
and laughs
if touched by these ice zombies the
plague will spread and the ice demons
will continue to attack
friends and enemies alike until pretty
much everyone has the deadly infection
omasa a fellow yakuza boss like hyogoro
gets infected and decides he will take
his own life so he doesn't infect his
allies
a very honorable thing to do but hyogoro
being the boss he is doesn't want to
give up hope too
soon he points out that there should be
a cure and if hope is eventually lost
and it's too late to save him
hyogero will do what has to be done and
cut down his friend without hesitation
mad respect a powerful moment and i
can't help but respect both of these
guys
for their behavior here even though
they're yakuza they have
a lot of honor we really see the horrors
of war here
while beast's pirate ice demon brother
is put up against non-infected beast
pirate brother
and the latter understandably mentions
that queen is being too
cruel it's actually chopper who cornered
with brook and robin mentions that queen
is here and he should have an antibody
on him after all
he might somehow get caught in it or
someone important in the crew
so he has to have that backup chopper
says that if they get the antibody
it wouldn't be too hard to produce more
but that's easier said than done because
as brook mentions
it had to be an all-star that had it
chopper knows that he's worried about
the after effects of being an ice demon
becoming a demon seems to increase
ferocity and strength
and includes abnormal freezing of the
skin too and a human body can't endure
that for long
this really is quite the concoction that
queen has released
so that even farther characters become a
way
bigger threat not only are they stronger
they become vessels for spreading the
ice demon
infection which can take out even the
strongest opponents
and then queen straight up says that
people who are infected will die
in an hour massively shortening the
window of hope
that the infected have it would be an
absolutely insane and tragic twist
if one of the straw hats was to get it
and queen just keeps being absolutely
brutal which not gonna lie
makes for a great antagonist he taunts
the infected laughing
and asking if these ice demons around
them bound for death were their friends
leaders and or subordinates and he says
make sure to kiss them goodbye but of
course anyone who did that would get
infected
as well and he just keeps laughing i
mean dude it is gonna feel really good
when queen gets his just desserts after
all of this
especially when he even treats his own
guys like this
you may think that queen is just willing
to sacrifice pleasures but he even makes
supernova scratchman
apu a target making his life way more
difficult
he supposedly throws him the one and
only antibody that exists in the world
and says that if anyone steals it from
the supernova it'll cost the supernova
his life i love how almost everyone is
freaking out but queen
is just having the time of his life
viewing it all as a live game show
it's almost like he's creating his own
version of the hunger games
and he says murder or betrayal anything
goes and he even wants to make sure our
guys have a chance to save themselves
so it's more interesting queen is pretty
much a mangaka in the manga
trying to make things as interesting and
intense as possible
and despite what a horrible person he is
i do appreciate all of these traits in
an antagonist
it ends up being zorro who gets charged
with getting the antibody from apu
and the crazy thing is even the bad guys
will be after him because they want the
antidote too but that's what you get a
poo for joining up with kaido and
betraying the others
queen has all but assured appu's death
here finally we get to yamato
for what is an epic part of the chapter
yamato is protecting shinobu
and momo from sasaki and other beast
pirates
susaki and the others aim to kill momo
following king's orders
but yamato is in their way shinobu now
very hurt
asks yamato to protect momo and yamato
promises
not only that but that she'll save
shinobu too
and we get a tragic reveal about her
past as well
not only does she say that 20 years ago
she was present at the execution of odin
she also says that she remembers shinobu
and was moved to tears by her words
she was moved to tears by how odin lived
his life
and that's how you judge a legend by how
they live their life
yamato goes on to protect them saying
that she rushed to the castle that day
to save momo but she could only watch as
his life was threatened and she
apologizes for that
she says she wasn't strong enough then
but as she kicks beast's pirate butt
and enrages and worried sasaki she
promises that this time she is ready to
die for momo
she also says that although she
introduced herself as odin
she's also known as yamato finally using
her real name
amazing stuff goosebump inducing
and so many great character moments in
this chapter from kiku to yamato
to hyogoro and even queen was great in
his own messed up villain kind of way
let me know what your favorite moment in
this chapter was
and what you thought of the whole
chapter in the comments and let me know
what you expect to see happen next
personally i feel like the ice demon
stuff is actually
super intense and interesting and i love
how queen just made
apu everyone's target and only hope to
survive
as always i can't wait for the next
chapter and although we didn't have any
super insane twists or anything
we learned important stuff about
yamato's tragic past where she was too
weak to interfere with her father
even though she knew what he was doing
was wrong and now she finally gets a
chance for redemption but anyways
thanks for watching this video if you
did enjoy this chapter and want to keep
them coming the best they could do
is hit that like button really smash
that like button turn it blue
and share this video with your nakama if
you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial
hit that notification bell and select
all or you will miss future one piece
videos
and while you wait for the next chapter
to drop feel free to check out my
growing one piece playlist where i got
videos about the yonko
warlord supernova and more and as i
mentioned i just dropped the longest
video
ever to be uploaded to our channel
recently about
every yonko's backstory so i'll link
that in the description as well
along with the full one piece playlist
and i especially want to thank the
patron squad over on patreon
and here on youtube who helped make
videos like this one possible
first and foremost i want to thank the
patrons of legend the ones acknowledged
by lord tuigo himself
alpha sigma and liam thompson and are
the one-tier patrons the ones who stand
atop all clans
in granada the world acquired respect
pate heffa jonathan king rathu and day
aura
red-haired raven emperor talk who thomas
jones
ken mono admirath christopher torley and
spidey light tin
l and are pro hero tier patrons the one
and only gilgamesh who's currently the
most donated overall champion
of the world nothing but a fan steelers
anatoly kazakie cricket xp
joe stanton very gucci jessica kayla
fond alicia actor hinokami and water
bonnie parks
florian joanne garcia mcshamus jack
watches anime deadly saint
and high school dxd thank you all so
much
if you do enjoy our work you can support
more of it by going over to patreon.com
animeapro and becoming a patreon today
for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get a name featured
in future videos alongside these amazing
people right here
and you'll even get access to our
private patron only discord
where we talk about anime life and of
course thank memes
so check out patreon.com anime upload
link in the description if you're
interested you can also join the youtube
channel by clicking that blue join
button next to the subscribe button that
you've hopefully already destroyed
so yeah you can support more content
that way if you prefer whichever way to
support us
you can get the same great benefits
thanks again
and until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you